- Bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo la Información
y Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous, y soy el director técnico
de Educación en IBM Quantum.
Esta es la segunda lección de la serie. Si todavía no
has visto la primera lección, asegúrate de verla.
Vamos a basarnos directamente en lo que hablamos
en la primera lección, así que es importante tener una
comprensión de ese material antes de esta lección.
También ten en cuenta que la serie
incluye contenido de libro de texto además de videos, y puedes encontrar un enlace
al contenido del libro de texto
en la descripción del video. Esta es la lección dos de
la unidad uno de la serie.
La unidad uno cubre los fundamentos
de la información cuántica.
En la lección anterior, hablamos sobre información cuántica en el contexto de sistemas individuales, lo que significa que tenemos un
sistema que almacena información
y describimos cómo
funciona de forma aislada.
Dedicamos bastante tiempo
a la información clásica, principalmente para establecer un punto de referencia y resaltar las
similitudes matemáticas
entre la información cuántica y la clásica.
También vimos cómo los estados cuánticos pueden representarse mediante vectores, específicamente vectores con
entradas de números complejos y norma euclidiana igual a uno,
y discutimos las mediciones en
base estándar y las operaciones unitarias.
En esta lección, vamos a ampliar nuestra
visión a múltiples sistemas, cada uno de los cuales es capaz de
almacenar información cuántica.
No se trata simplemente de decir que cada sistema individual
funciona como discutimos la última vez; en cierto sentido, el todo
es mayor que la suma de sus partes, y eso también es válido para
la información clásica cuando hay probabilidades involucradas.
Los múltiples sistemas pueden
interactuar entre sí y pueden estar correlacionados
entre sí, por ejemplo, y en el contexto cuántico, esto incluye la posibilidad
de que los sistemas estén entrelazados, un término que
quizás ya hayas escuchado antes.
El entrelazamiento es un fenómeno
muy importante en la información cuántica y tendremos mucho más que decir al respecto a medida que la serie continúe.
Sin embargo, hay un principio simple que nos ofrece bastante tracción para pensar y
entender la información cuántica en múltiples sistemas,
y es que siempre podemos
tomar dos o más sistemas y unirlos, o simplemente
pensarlos juntos de forma conceptual
y verlos como si formaran
un único sistema compuesto.
Y cuando pensamos en un
sistema compuesto así, como si fuera un solo sistema, reconocemos que debe describirse de una manera que sea consistente
con todo lo que aprendimos
en la lección anterior sobre sistemas individuales.
Veremos cómo funciona esto
y cómo la descripción de la información cuántica
para múltiples sistemas surge de forma bastante natural a partir de cómo funciona para sistemas individuales
basándonos en este único principio. Aquí hay un resumen de la lección y resulta que es idéntico al resumen de la lección anterior,
pero esta vez nuestro enfoque
estará en múltiples sistemas en lugar de sistemas individuales.
Al igual que en la lección anterior y por exactamente las mismas razones, vamos a empezar con
la información clásica.
Una vez más, veremos
similitudes muy estrechas entre la forma en que la información
cuántica y la clásica funcionan a nivel matemático.
Por lo general, no nos centraremos tanto
en la información clásica ni comenzaremos cada lección de la serie con información clásica de esta manera.
Las lecciones posteriores tenderán a enfocarse mucho más exclusivamente en la información y computación cuántica.
Pero aquí al principio
este es un enfoque sensato y vuelve a la idea de que pensar en la información clásica
puede servir como una valiosa fuente de orientación para entender la información cuántica.
También vamos a discutir
el importante concepto del producto tensorial en
esta parte de la lección.
Los productos tensoriales son de vital importancia en la información cuántica, pero también surgen en
el contexto clásico.
Luego pasaremos a la información cuántica y, al igual que en la lección anterior, discutiremos estados cuánticos,
mediciones en base estándar,
y operaciones unitarias, esta
vez para múltiples sistemas.
Empezaremos hablando
sobre los estados clásicos de múltiples sistemas.
Recuerda de la lección anterior
que un estado clásico de un sistema es una
configuración de ese sistema que puede reconocerse y
describirse de forma inequívoca
sin ninguna incertidumbre ni error. Y en términos matemáticos, cuando nos referimos a un conjunto de estados clásicos,
simplemente nos referimos a un conjunto finito y no vacío.
Comenzaremos nuestra discusión
sobre múltiples sistemas suponiendo que tenemos
solo dos sistemas X e Y.
X tiene un conjunto de estados clásicos al que llamaremos sigma, igual que
en la lección anterior, e Y tiene un conjunto de estados clásicos
al que llamaremos gamma. El conjunto sigma y gamma
podrían ser el mismo conjunto o podrían ser diferentes,
pero les damos nombres distintos, no solo porque
podrían ser conjuntos diferentes, sino también porque nos ayudará
a mantener las cosas claras si les damos nombres diferentes.
Veremos que es
bastante fácil generalizar toda esta discusión de dos sistemas a cualquier número de sistemas, pero
al comenzar con dos sistemas,
podemos centrarnos en las ideas fundamentales sin perdernos en los detalles.
Ahora, imagina que
ponemos X e Y uno al lado del otro con X a la izquierda e Y a la derecha, y vemos estos dos sistemas juntos
como si formaran un único sistema compuesto.
para darle un nombre a este nuevo sistema, podemos escribirlo como un
par ordenado así, o simplemente podemos yuxtaponer
las dos letras de esta forma.
Ambas formas son comunes y
podemos elegir la que queramos o la que nos resulte más conveniente.
De cualquier manera, lo leeremos como XY.
Una pregunta muy natural
que surge en este punto es: ¿cuáles son los estados clásicos de este nuevo sistema compuesto XY?
Y la respuesta a esa pregunta es que el conjunto de estados clásicos de XY es el producto cartesiano de
los dos conjuntos de estados clásicos,
sigma y gamma, que puedes
ver definidos justo aquí.
En un momento dado, X tiene algún estado clásico
que es un elemento de sigma, e Y tiene algún estado clásico
que es un elemento de gamma,
y simplemente estamos pensando
en estos dos estados juntos como si formaran un solo estado, y esa es precisamente la noción
que captura el producto cartesiano. Tenemos dos elementos,
uno de cada uno de nuestros conjuntos, y queremos pensar en
estos dos elementos juntos
como si formaran un solo
elemento de un único conjunto.
Para ser claros, aquí hay una suposición: que sabemos
cuál de nuestros sistemas es X y cuál es Y,
y no hay confusión entre ellos. No importa que X esté físicamente a la izquierda
e Y a la derecha,
sino que los dos
sistemas son distinguibles y que hemos decidido
ordenarlos de esta manera para poder mantener
claro cuál es cuál.
Aquí hay un ejemplo muy simple donde sigma es el alfabeto binario y gamma es el conjunto
que contiene los cuatro palos de la baraja.
Si X almacena un valor binario e Y almacena uno de los cuatro palos de la baraja, entonces hay ocho
posibles estados clásicos
del par XY, que puedes
ver listados aquí.
Para más de dos sistemas, esto se generaliza de manera directa.
En particular, si X1 a Xn son sistemas que tienen conjuntos de
estados clásicos sigma uno a sigma n respectivamente.
Entonces, si imaginamos agrupar
los n sistemas y verlos como un solo sistema, el conjunto de estados clásicos viene
dado por el producto cartesiano
de los n conjuntos de estados clásicos
sigma uno a sigma n.
Como puedes ver aquí en la pantalla. El producto cartesiano
puede definirse así para cualquier número de conjuntos.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos tres sistemas y todos comparten el alfabeto binario como su conjunto de estados clásicos, es decir, tenemos tres bits,
entonces hay ocho
posibles estados clásicos de los tres bits vistos
juntos como un único sistema, y puedes verlos listados aquí.
Cada sistema individualmente puede
estar en el estado cero o uno, y recorremos todas las
posibles combinaciones.
Una n-tupla de estados clásicos puede escribirse alternativamente como una cadena donde omitimos los
paréntesis y las comas, como ves aquí.
Y esto es especialmente sensato cuando pensamos en los
estados clásicos como símbolos, como en el ejemplo muy común
del alfabeto binario
al que seguimos volviendo. A veces es muy conveniente hacer esto y tiende a hacer
nuestras expresiones más simples
y menos cargadas. La noción de cadena está de hecho formalizada
en términos matemáticos a través de los productos cartesianos,
así que esto es realmente solo
una notación alternativa y no algo conceptualmente diferente.
Como ejemplo, digamos que tenemos
10 bits X1 a X10.
Eso significa que el conjunto de estados clásicos de los 10 bits juntos,
que naturalmente podrías pensar como un registro de 10 bits
en una computadora, por ejemplo,
es el producto cartesiano décuple
del alfabeto binario consigo mismo.
Y si escribimos esos estados como cadenas, se ven como ves aquí,
hay 1.024 de ellos,
así que por supuesto no están todos listados aquí. Estos tres puntos de aquí
se supone que indican que hay un patrón que puedes deducir
y esperamos que captes la idea. Ahora hay una convención
que vamos a seguir para ordenar los elementos
de los conjuntos producto cartesiano,
y es importante
aclarar esto para poder representar tanto los estados probabilísticos como los estados cuánticos como vectores.
La convención es que
ordenamos los elementos de los conjuntos producto cartesiano
lexicográficamente, lo que básicamente significa
orden de diccionario.
Para ser más específicos, partimos de la suposición de que cada uno de los conjuntos individuales del producto cartesiano ya tiene su propio orden
y pensamos en una
n-tupla o cadena dada como si fuera una palabra y las
ordenamos alfabéticamente.
Otra forma de decirlo es que las posiciones dentro de
una n-tupla o cadena disminuyen en significancia
de izquierda a derecha,
igual que cuando escribimos números usando los dígitos del cero al nueve.
Aquí hay un ejemplo que
pretende aclarar esto.
Si tomamos el producto cartesiano entre los conjuntos que contienen
uno, dos y tres y el alfabeto binario, obtenemos un conjunto con seis elementos
y aquí están listados en el
orden que se está describiendo.
Todos los elementos con un
uno en la primera posición van antes que todos los elementos con un dos en la primera posición, y estos van antes que todos los elementos
con un tres en la primera posición. Y cuando dos elementos
coinciden en la primera posición, recurrimos al orden
de la segunda posición.
Ese es el orden que
usamos para los productos cartesianos.
Nota que cuando usamos esta convención y escribimos las n-tuplas como cadenas, observamos algunos patrones muy familiares.
Por ejemplo, el producto cartesiano del
alfabeto binario consigo mismo está ordenado como ves aquí,
y puedes pensar en estas cadenas como ordenadas numéricamente si las tomas
como codificaciones binarias de enteros no negativos,
y esto se generaliza
a cualquier longitud de cadena. Pasando a los estados probabilísticos, ya sabemos por la lección anterior
que un estado probabilístico asocia una probabilidad con cada estado
clásico de un sistema dado.
Si tenemos un sistema compuesto donde hemos tomado dos o más sistemas y los vemos colectivamente como si formaran un único
sistema, tal como acabamos de comentar,
entonces un estado probabilístico
de este sistema compuesto debe asignar probabilidades a los elementos del producto cartesiano
de los sistemas individuales,
conjuntos de estados clásicos. Eso se debe a que ese es
el conjunto de estados clásicos del sistema compuesto.
Por ejemplo, suponiendo
que X e Y son bits, tenemos este ejemplo de un
estado probabilístico de XY.
La probabilidad de que ambos
bits sean cero es un medio y la probabilidad de que ambos
bits sean uno es un medio, por lo que los dos bits nunca discrepan.
Es un estado probabilístico válido de XY, y alternativamente
podemos escribirlo como un vector
como ves aquí, y aquí puedes ver que
estamos siguiendo la convención que describí hace un momento para ordenar estos estados clásicos.
Este es un ejemplo de
un estado probabilístico donde X e Y están correlacionados, y este es el sentido en que el todo
es mayor que la suma de las partes. Como sugerí antes, no es simplemente que
tengamos un estado probabilístico
de X y un estado probabilístico de Y que juntamos, sino que primero juntamos
los sistemas
y luego pensamos en
los estados probabilísticos del sistema compuesto.
Para ser más precisos sobre
las correlaciones entre sistemas, comenzamos definiendo la
noción de independencia, que es esencialmente la
ausencia de correlación.
Aquí, por cierto, el término independencia se refiere
a la independencia estadística, en oposición a la independencia lineal
de vectores, por ejemplo.
Es una noción fundamental en
probabilidad y estadística.
Si tenemos dos sistemas X e Y y tenemos en mente algún estado probabilístico
de XY, entonces decimos que X e Y son independientes.
Si la fórmula que
ves aquí es cierta para toda elección de estados
clásicos a y b de X e Y.
Una forma de interpretar esta
condición de independencia es que dice que la probabilidad de que X esté en cualquier estado clásico
y la probabilidad de que Y esté en algún otro estado clásico no tienen absolutamente nada
que ver entre sí.
Entonces, saber en qué estado
está uno de los sistemas no afecta las
probabilidades asociadas con los estados del otro sistema.
Si imaginas elegir aleatoriamente
algún estado clásico de X según algún procedimiento y luego elegir aleatoriamente
algún estado clásico de Y
según algún otro procedimiento que no esté de ninguna manera
relacionado con el de X, como si una persona lanza una moneda
y otra persona en una
habitación diferente lanza un dado, entonces esta es la fórmula
que usarías para obtener las probabilidades
de las distintas combinaciones
de estados. El punto de la definición es que la independencia se da
cuando la fórmula es válida.
Cuando pensamos en los estados probabilísticos en términos de vectores de probabilidad, hay una formulación simple
de esta condición
específicamente si tenemos un
estado probabilístico de XY, que podemos expresar como un
vector en la notación directa
como ves aquí. Entonces, decir que X e Y son independientes equivale a la existencia
de dos vectores de probabilidad,
ket Phi y ket Psi, que por cierto podemos
leer simplemente como Phi y Psi para abreviar, representando
estados probabilísticos de X e Y por separado que satisfacen esta igualdad
que ves aquí.
Para toda elección de a y b, es esencialmente una
reformulación de la definición en términos de vectores.
Por ejemplo, aquí hay un estado probabilístico
de un par de bits XY para el cual X e Y son independientes.
La condición que se
requiere para la independencia es cierta para los vectores
que ves aquí.
Es decir, la probabilidad
de cada posible configuración de los dos bits viene dada por el producto de las probabilidades correspondientes
de los bits individuales.
Por ejemplo, la probabilidad de que ambos
bits tomen el valor cero es igual a un sexto, que es igual a un
cuarto por dos tercios,
y lo mismo para las
otras tres posibilidades, que se pueden verificar una por una.
Para el estado probabilístico que vimos antes, en cambio, donde
tenemos dos bits que siempre coinciden y toman los valores cero y
uno con probabilidad un medio,
no tenemos independencia y por eso decimos que
los bits están correlacionados.
Correlación simplemente significa
ausencia de independencia.
Una forma sencilla de demostrar que los
dos bits no son independientes es suponer que lo son y llegar a una contradicción.
Específicamente, si los dos
bits fueran independientes, tendrían que existir
números q0, q1, r0 y r1
que representen probabilidades
de los dos bits individuales, de modo que estas ecuaciones
de aquí se satisfagan.
Estas son las probabilidades
que provienen de nuestro vector y estas son las
ecuaciones que deben ser ciertas según la condición de independencia,
pero si echamos un vistazo a esta
segunda igualdad aquí, vemos que exige que
q0 por r1 sea igual a cero,
pero la única forma en que el
producto de dos números reales puede ser igual a cero es que al menos uno de esos
números sea igual a cero.
A esto se le llama a veces
la propiedad del producto cero de los números reales.
Otra forma de decirlo es que el producto de dos números reales no nulos
es siempre no nulo.
Así que esta igualdad
de aquí implica que o bien q0 es igual a cero o bien r1 es igual a cero,
pero de la primera y la última igualdad vemos que ninguna de
esas dos alternativas puede ser verdadera.
Si q0 es igual a cero, entonces este producto debe ser igual a cero, pero no es igual a cero,
y si r1 es igual a cero,
entonces este producto debe ser igual a cero, pero eso tampoco es verdad.
Entonces tenemos una contradicción
y concluimos que X e Y no son independientes, o sea que están correlacionadas.
La noción de independencia
que acabamos de ver y, en particular, su formulación en términos de vectores de probabilidad está estrechamente relacionada
con una operación que se puede
realizar sobre vectores conocida como el producto tensorial.
Los productos tensoriales se pueden
definir no solo para vectores sino también para matrices,
y de hecho la noción de producto tensorial se puede definir
para muchos otros tipos de
objetos matemáticos también.
Se pueden describir
de una manera bastante abstracta que es importante y
útil en matemática pura, pero también podemos definir
los productos tensoriales para vectores
de una forma muy sencilla y concreta, y ese es el camino que
seguiremos en esta lección.
Si tenemos dos vectores columna Phi y Psi escritos en las formas que ves aquí, donde sigma y gamma son cualquier
elección de conjuntos de estados clásicos
que queramos, o índices si lo prefieres, entonces el producto tensorial de estos vectores es el vector que ves justo aquí.
Recorremos todos los elementos
del producto cartesiano de los dos conjuntos, sigma y gamma, y la entrada de este
vector que corresponde
a cada par ab, que se escribe
como una cadena aquí, es igual al producto de
las entradas correspondientes
de estos dos vectores. En otras palabras, la entrada ab de Phi tensor Psi es el producto de la entrada a
de Phi y la entrada b de Psi,
y ese es el significado de
lo que está escrito aquí.
En esencia, esta es la misma operación que acabamos de ver hace unos momentos cuando hablamos de independencia
y ahora simplemente le damos un nombre.
Aquí está exactamente el mismo ejemplo
que vimos hace un momento, escrito de forma más explícita en
términos del producto tensorial.
De nuevo, tenemos que un sexto es igual a un cuarto por un tercio, un doceavo es igual a un cuarto
por un tercio, y así sucesivamente.
Aquí, por cierto, hay un
par de formas alternativas de escribir el producto
tensorial de dos vectores.
Cuando usamos la notación de ket y escribimos dos kets
uno al lado del otro así, significa el producto tensorial.
Así que puedes pensar en el producto tensorial como la forma predeterminada de multiplicar dos vectores columna entre sí.
No tendría ningún sentido
pensar en un producto de vectores columna así en términos de multiplicación matricial porque las dimensiones no encajan,
así que realmente no hay motivo de
preocupación por ambigüedad aquí.
También podemos escribir el
producto tensorial así dentro de un ket, y significa
exactamente lo mismo.
Es el producto tensorial
de los dos vectores.
La primera forma es muy común y, de hecho, quizás es más común escribir un producto tensorial así sin el símbolo de producto tensorial
que incluir el símbolo. La segunda es
definitivamente mucho menos común, pero a veces es bastante útil, principalmente
como una forma de eliminar la necesidad
de paréntesis adicionales en ciertas situaciones.
También podemos expresar
los productos tensoriales de forma explícita en términos de columnas de
números reales, como ves aquí,
si tomamos el producto tensorial de estos dos vectores columna de aquí, entonces este es el vector que obtenemos
y puedes ver que las entradas aquí son productos de las entradas
provenientes de estos dos vectores.
El orden de las entradas
del producto tensorial es coherente con la
definición de hace un momento, siempre que sigamos la convención
que describí antes para ordenar los elementos
de los conjuntos producto cartesiano.
Seguir esa convención equivale a pensar
que los índices del primer vector tienen
mayor peso que los índices del segundo vector,
así que puedes ver que al
recorrer las entradas del producto tensorial, tenemos todos los productos que involucran la primera entrada del
vector de la izquierda,
que es alpha uno. Luego todos los productos
que involucran la segunda entrada del vector de la izquierda,
que es alpha dos, y así sucesivamente.
Aquí hay un ejemplo donde
el vector de la izquierda tiene tres entradas y el vector de la
derecha tiene cuatro entradas, para que podamos ver más
claramente lo que está pasando.
Tenemos tres entradas en el primer vector, así que empezamos escribiendo tres copias del segundo vector y luego multiplicamos cada una de esas copias
por la entrada correspondiente
del primer vector, así.
Metemos los alphas adentro así, y aquí simplemente estamos
multiplicando vectores por escalares
y finalmente quitamos los
paréntesis de las copias y formamos un único vector
columna como ves aquí.
Como apunte importante, observa que tenemos las siguientes fórmulas para el producto tensorial de
vectores de la base estándar.
Si tomamos el producto
tensorial del ket a y el ket b, que podemos escribir con
el símbolo de producto tensorial o sin él, como ves aquí,
entonces el resultado es simplemente el ket ab.
Si queremos escribir ab como un par ordenado en lugar de una cadena, podemos hacerlo y obtenemos
esta expresión aquí,
pero es mucho más común
escribir esto de aquí, donde omitimos los paréntesis
pero dejamos la coma.
Hay un sentido en el que
esta con los paréntesis es quizás más correcta, pero es una convención bastante estándar en matemáticas
que los paréntesis se eliminan cuando no son necesarios ni útiles.
Puedes pensar que están implícitos en este de aquí y simplemente es menos desordenado
y más agradable a la vista.
El producto tensorial tiene
una propiedad importante que es que es bilineal, y lo que eso significa es que es lineal
en cada uno de los dos argumentos, siempre que el otro esté fijo.
Con un poco más de detalle, es
lineal en el primer argumento, lo cual se expresa mediante estas dos ecuaciones que ves aquí,
la primera dice que
si sumamos dos vectores, Phi1 y Phi2, y luego tomamos
el producto tensorial con Psi, obtenemos el mismo resultado que si
hubiéramos tomado el producto tensorial
con Psi primero y luego sumáramos.
La segunda dice que si
multiplicamos algún vector Phi por algún escalar alpha y luego tomamos el
producto tensorial con Psi,
el resultado es el mismo que si primero tomáramos el producto tensorial de Phi y Psi y luego multiplicáramos el resultado por alpha.
Y también tenemos linealidad
en el segundo argumento, que es lo mismo salvo que los roles de los dos argumentos están intercambiados.
Esta propiedad de bilinealidad
es bastante sencilla de verificar a partir de la definición, pero es útil escribirla así porque a menudo
haremos uso de estas fórmulas.
Observa, por cierto, que los escalares fluyen libremente a través de los productos tensoriales en el sentido que expresan estas
igualdades que ves aquí.
Es decir, no hay diferencia
entre multiplicar el primer argumento por un
escalar alpha, en este caso multiplicar el segundo
argumento por ese escalar,
o multiplicar todo
el resultado por ese escalar.
Estas igualdades se derivan de
estas dos ecuaciones de aquí y, como no hay
diferencia entre estos vectores, podemos simplemente escribir la
expresión como ves aquí
sin paréntesis porque
no hacen falta.
No añaden claridad
ni eliminan ambigüedad, así que simplemente los quitamos y
obtenemos una expresión más limpia.
Todo esto se generaliza
a tres o más sistemas.
Podemos definir el producto tensorial
de tres o más vectores generalizando la fórmula
del producto tensorial de dos vectores de la manera natural,
que puedes ver expresada aquí. Cada entrada del producto tensorial viene dada por el producto de
las entradas correspondientes
de los vectores de los que estamos
tomando el producto tensorial.
Una forma equivalente de
definir el producto tensorial de tres o más vectores
es hacerlo de manera recursiva, cayendo en última instancia en la definición
del producto tensorial entre dos vectores. Así que si n es al menos tres, podemos pensar en el
producto tensorial de n vectores
Phi1 hasta Phi n como el producto tensorial entre el vector que obtenemos al
tomar el producto tensorial de los primeros n menos uno
con el último vector,
y si quieres saber
cuál es el producto tensorial de los primeros n menos uno vectores, o bien aplicas la fórmula
de nuevo en caso de que n menos uno
sea al menos tres, o usas la definición
anterior si n menos uno es igual a dos.
Las dos formas de pensar
en los productos tensoriales de tres o más vectores son equivalentes.
En este caso, cuando tenemos
tres o más vectores de los que tomamos el producto tensorial, no usamos el término bilineal,
sino que usamos el término multilineal,
pero la idea es la misma.
El producto tensorial es lineal
en cada una de las posiciones, siempre que los vectores en
todas las demás posiciones
estén fijos. Pasando a las mediciones
de sistemas múltiples en estados probabilísticos,
obtenemos inmediatamente una especificación de cómo funcionan las mediciones
para sistemas múltiples con solo pensar en ellos
colectivamente como sistemas únicos
siempre que todos los
sistemas sean medidos.
Como ejemplo sencillo, supongamos que tenemos dos
bits X e Y, y colectivamente están en este estado probabilístico de aquí,
que vimos antes. Naturalmente, si medimos
ambos bits, obtendremos el resultado 00
es decir, un cero para la primera medición y un cero para la segunda medición con probabilidad un medio, y obtendremos el resultado 1,1
con probabilidad un medio también. Eso es bastante directo.
En esencia, medir todos los sistemas equivale a medir
el sistema compuesto completo.
Si no medimos todos
los sistemas, sin embargo, sino que solo medimos
algunos de ellos, entonces la situación no es
tan inmediatamente clara
restringiendo nuestra atención una vez más al caso de solo dos
sistemas para ver la esencia de lo que ocurre en un
contexto lo más simple posible.
Podemos hacer la siguiente pregunta: supongamos que tenemos dos sistemas, X e Y, que están juntos como un par
en algún estado probabilístico particular.
¿Qué ocurre si medimos
solo X y no hacemos nada a Y?
Bien, podemos responder esta pregunta usando algo de teoría básica de probabilidad.
Primero, sabemos que la probabilidad de que la medición
dé un resultado particular tiene que venir dada por esta fórmula
que ves aquí.
Podemos pensar en las probabilidades de cada uno de los
estados clásicos del par XY como si hubiéramos medido ambos, y sumamos todas las probabilidades
que son consistentes con X estando en cualquier estado clásico
a que nos interese.
Por eso la suma de aquí es solo sobre los estados clásicos b de Y.
Una forma de pensar en esta
fórmula es que la probabilidad de ver un estado clásico particular
de X si lo medimos
tiene que ser consistente con la probabilidad de ver ese estado si
también hubiéramos medido Y, aunque no lo hayamos hecho,
eso es muy natural e intuitivo. La probabilidad de que una medición de X produzca un resultado particular no puede depender de si Y
también fue medida
independientemente del resultado.
Entonces eso nos dice cuáles
son las probabilidades para los distintos posibles
resultados de la medición, pero ¿qué le pasa a Y o a nuestro
conocimiento de Y como resultado?
La respuesta es que todavía
podría existir cierta incertidumbre sobre el estado de Y como
resultado de haber medido X
y haber visto un resultado particular. Y esa incertidumbre está representada por esta fórmula de aquí para la probabilidad condicional
de que Y esté en algún estado
clásico particular b, dado que X está en algún estado clásico,
cualquier estado clásico a
que hayamos medido.
Para ser precisos, la probabilidad de que Y esté
en algún estado clásico b, dado que X está en el estado clásico a,
es igual a la probabilidad
de que X esté en a e Y esté en b dividida por la probabilidad de que X
esté en el estado clásico a.
Entonces si medimos X, vamos a ver
distintos estados clásicos con probabilidades determinadas
por esta fórmula de aquí
y dependiendo del resultado que obtengamos, puede que todavía tengamos cierta incertidumbre sobre el estado clásico de Y y
esa incertidumbre se refleja
en esta fórmula de aquí.
En realidad hay una forma muy sencilla
de reformular todo esto y realizar cálculos
para casos específicos usando la notación directa
y funciona así.
Empezamos escribiendo el
estado probabilístico de XY como un vector así, y
esto es completamente general.
Las entradas se denotan por Pab y estos pueden ser cualquier número siempre que el vector completo
sea un vector de probabilidad.
Podemos expresar el ket ab como un
producto tensorial como ves aquí y luego podemos usar la
bilinealidad del producto tensorial
y específicamente el hecho de que es lineal en el segundo argumento para expresar este vector
tal como ves aquí.
Lo que estamos haciendo es efectivamente aislar los vectores de la base estándar
en el lado izquierdo y poner lo que necesitemos
en el lado derecho
para lograrlo, porque eso va a revelar qué pasa cuando
medimos el primer sistema X.
Concretamente, la probabilidad
de obtener un resultado particular a es la suma de todas las probabilidades que aparecen entre
paréntesis junto al ket a.
Y condicionado a obtener
un resultado particular a, el vector de probabilidad que describe la incertidumbre que queda sobre Y
es el vector que estaba entre
paréntesis junto a a.
Solo que tenemos que normalizarlo para convertirlo en un vector de probabilidad, lo que significa que
tenemos que dividir ese vector
por la suma de las entradas de ese vector para formar un vector de probabilidad.
Por cierto, aquí la suma se toma sobre todo
c en gamma en lugar de b, solo para usar un nombre de variable diferente y así no haya ninguna confusión
sobre el alcance de las
variables, por así decirlo.
Las sumas en el numerador
y en el denominador deben considerarse como cosas separadas y podemos evitar cualquier posibilidad
de confusión al respecto
usando distintas
variables para las dos sumas.
Aquí va un ejemplo rápido para
ilustrar cómo funciona todo esto.
Supongamos que XY es un par de bits en este estado probabilístico de aquí; para entender qué pasa
cuando medimos el primer bit
y no hacemos nada con el segundo, escribimos el vector como ves aquí, donde el ket cero y el ket
uno en la primera posición
quedan aislados tal como
describimos hace un momento.
La primera posibilidad es
que el resultado de la medición sea cero y la probabilidad
de que eso ocurra es la suma de las probabilidades
dentro de los paréntesis
que están en producto tensorial con el ket cero. Así obtenemos un doceavo más un cuarto, que es un tercio, y
condicionado al resultado cero.
El estado probabilístico de Y
se convierte en este vector normalizado, o equivalentemente dividido por la probabilidad
que acabamos de calcular, y lo que obtenemos es
este vector de aquí.
La segunda posibilidad es que el resultado de la medición sea uno y el cálculo se
hace de manera similar usando el segundo término de la expresión
en lugar del primer término. Y si quieres verificar los detalles, adelante, como siempre, pausa el video para darte un momento y hacerlo.
Puedes realizar los mismos
tipos de cálculos para ver qué pasa cuando
se mide Y en lugar de X.
Es el mismo método, con la diferencia de la simetría entre los dos sistemas.
Esta vez escribimos el
vector de probabilidad así, aislando los vectores de la base estándar en el lado derecho tal como ves aquí,
pero por lo demás funciona
exactamente de la misma manera.
También puedes usar este método
para más de dos sistemas.
Puede volverse un poco
engorroso escribir todas las expresiones necesarias, pero conceptualmente es
exactamente la misma idea.
Por último, en la parte de la lección
sobre información clásica, vamos a ver las operaciones
sobre estados probabilísticos
de múltiples sistemas. Siguiendo el mismo razonamiento que ya hemos visto un par de veces.
Concluimos que las operaciones probabilísticas sobre múltiples sistemas son igual
que las operaciones probabilísticas sobre sistemas individuales, representadas
por matrices estocásticas.
Pero esta vez esas matrices
tienen filas y columnas que corresponden al producto cartesiano de los conjuntos de estados clásicos de cada sistema.
Es decir, simplemente estamos
viendo un sistema compuesto como si fuera un único sistema y recurriendo a la descripción de cómo funcionan las operaciones probabilísticas
para sistemas individuales de
la lección anterior.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de una operación llamada operación NOT controlada
sobre dos bits X e Y.
Esta es en realidad una operación determinista y la forma en que funciona es
que si X es igual a uno, se realiza una operación NOT sobre Y
y de lo contrario, si X es igual
a cero, no ocurre nada.
El bit X se llama a veces
bit de control porque determina si
se aplica o no la operación NOT a Y
e Y se llama el bit objetivo porque es el bit sobre el que actúa la operación NOT.
También puedes imaginar
intercambiar los roles de X e Y para que Y se convierta en el bit
de control y X se convierta en el objetivo, pero esa es una operación diferente
a la que se describe aquí, porque la operación no es
simétrica entre X e Y.
Ambas se llaman
operaciones NOT controladas, y solo necesitamos especificar
cuál de los bits es el bit de control y
cuál es el bit objetivo.
Esta operación tiene la acción
que ves aquí sobre los estados de la base estándar, y puedes verificar esa
acción con la definición
de la operación. Y aquí está la representación matricial de la operación.
Cuando pensamos en esta operación, tenemos en mente que hay
estos dos bits separados que desempeñan los roles que acabo de describir, con
X siendo el bit de control
e Y siendo el bit objetivo, pero en realidad no hay nada
en esta acción ni en esta representación matricial
que nos obligue a
pensar en estos dos bits como bits separados.
Alternativamente, podríamos simplemente
pensar en esta operación como una operación determinista
sobre un sistema con cuatro estados clásicos
que hemos decidido nombrar
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 y 1,1.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo de
una operación probabilista sobre dos bits, que esta vez no es una operación determinista.
La operación establece que Y sea igual a X con probabilidad de un medio, y de lo contrario ocurre al revés y establece que X sea igual a Y.
Esta operación no tiene un nombre especial, es solo un ejemplo.
Y aquí está la representación matricial de esta operación.
Puedes ver que puede expresarse como un promedio de dos matrices, una que representa la operación determinista
donde Y se establece con el valor
almacenado en X, y la otra que establece
que X sea igual a Y.
Así que aquí vemos que podemos calcular promedios de matrices estocásticas para obtener nuevas, tal como ocurría en la lección anterior.
Ahora, consideremos
la siguiente pregunta. Supongamos que tenemos dos
operaciones probabilistas, cada una sobre su propio sistema
descritas como de costumbre por matrices estocásticas, y para ser precisos, supongamos que M es
una operación probabilista
sobre un sistema X, y N es una
operación probabilista sobre un sistema Y.
La pregunta es: si realizamos
simultáneamente M sobre X y N sobre Y, ¿cómo describimos
el efecto que esto tiene
sobre el sistema compuesto XY?
Pensando en esto
intuitivamente por un momento, si realizamos simultáneamente
las dos operaciones sobre sus respectivos sistemas,
entonces de hecho estamos
realizando una operación sobre el sistema compuesto, por lo que debería describirse
mediante alguna matriz estocástica.
La respuesta breve a esta
pregunta es que la matriz se obtiene calculando un producto tensorial, no entre vectores como
comentamos antes,
sino entre matrices, en este
caso las matrices M y N.
Así que tomemos unos momentos
para hablar sobre los productos tensoriales de matrices y luego
volveremos a esta pregunta.
Aquí está la definición
del producto tensorial entre matrices, y
es muy análoga al producto tensorial entre vectores.
Si suponemos que las dos
matrices con las que trabajamos están escritas en las formas que ves aquí, de modo que las entradas de M se
denotan como alpha ab con a y b
recorriendo algún conjunto de estados clásicos sigma, y las entradas de N se
denotan por beta cd con c y d
recorriendo algún conjunto de estados clásicos gamma.
Entonces el producto de M y N es la matriz que ves aquí.
Lo que tenemos es similar
al producto tensorial entre vectores.
las filas y columnas de M tensor N corresponden a pares de estados clásicos que se escriben como cadenas aquí,
y las entradas son productos de las entradas correspondientes de M y N.
Aquí hay otra forma de escribirlo en términos de las entradas individuales de estas matrices.
La entrada ac bd de M tensor N es el producto de la entrada ab
de M y la entrada cd de N.
Hay otra forma de
describir M tensor N, que es que es la
única matriz que transforma cualquier vector de la forma Phi tensor Psi
en el producto tensorial de M aplicada a Phi con N aplicada a Psi, y eso debe ser válido para cualquier elección
de estos vectores Phi y Psi.
Una forma de pensar en esto
es que el producto tensorial de matrices se lleva perfectamente bien con el producto tensorial entre vectores.
Esta es una ecuación que
esperarías naturalmente que sea cierta y, en efecto, lo es.
En términos de matrices
escritas de forma explícita, podemos definir el producto tensorial como ves aquí.
Hay muchos puntos en esta ecuación y están destinados a
ilustrar el patrón, que es el mismo patrón
que teníamos para los vectores, excepto que ahora tenemos filas y columnas
en lugar de simples vectores columna.
En caso de que no quede claro,
el siguiente ejemplo puede ayudar.
Aquí hablamos del
producto tensorial de dos matrices de dos por dos.
Primero escribimos cuatro
copias de la segunda matriz, una por cada entrada de la primera matriz.
Multiplicamos cada una de estas
copias de la segunda matriz por la entrada
correspondiente de la primera matriz,
y luego lo agrupamos todo en
una única matriz de cuatro por cuatro, como ves aquí mismo.
También podemos definir el
producto tensorial de tres o más matrices de forma análoga, y quizás la manera más sencilla
de expresar esto
es como ves aquí mismo,
donde tenemos una fórmula para cada entrada del producto tensorial, que no es más que el producto
de las entradas correspondientes.
También puedes definir el producto tensorial de tres o más matrices de forma recursiva en términos del producto
tensorial de solo dos matrices, igual que hicimos con los vectores.
Y una última nota: el
producto tensorial de matrices es multiplicativo, lo que significa que un
producto de productos tensoriales
es igual al producto
tensorial de los productos.
Puedes pensar en esto como
una generalización de la fórmula de hace un momento para la acción del producto
tensorial de matrices
sobre el producto tensorial de vectores. Y de nuevo, esto es algo que
sin duda esperaríamos que fuera cierto, y podemos alegrarnos de que lo sea.
Haremos uso de este
hecho siempre que lo necesitemos.
Y ahora podemos volver a
la pregunta de antes, que nos pregunta cómo describimos
el efecto de realizar una operación M sobre un sistema X
y una operación N sobre el sistema Y juntas como una operación
sobre el sistema compuesto XY.
Y la respuesta a esa
pregunta es que la acción se describe mediante el
producto tensorial de M y N.
Los productos tensoriales representan independencia, esta vez entre operaciones, a diferencia de lo que vimos
antes con los vectores de probabilidad.
Aquí va un ejemplo rápido. Supongamos que realizamos
la operación probabilística descrita por esta matriz sobre un bit X.
Esta resulta ser una operación
que vimos en la lección uno, y que simultáneamente realizamos
una operación NOT sobre un bit Y.
La operación combinada sobre el par XY queda representada, por tanto, por el producto tensorial de las matrices correspondientes a estas dos operaciones.
Aquí está la del X y
aquí está la operación NOT sobre Y, y obtenemos esta matriz
que ves aquí mismo.
Y puedes ver que, en efecto,
esta es una matriz estocástica, y ese siempre será el caso.
El producto tensorial de dos
matrices estocásticas cualesquiera, o de cualquier número de matrices estocásticas,
siempre será estocástico.
Es muy habitual encontrarse
con una situación en la que se realiza una operación sobre un sistema
y no se hace nada sobre otro sistema.
En esa situación, seguimos exactamente la misma prescripción, con el entendido de que no hacer nada se representa con la matriz identidad.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos dos bits X e
Y y reiniciamos el bit X al estado cero, que es lo mismo
que aplicar la función
constante cero sobre X y no hacer nada sobre Y, entonces la operación resultante sobre el par XY
queda representada por este
producto tensorial que ves aquí.
Todo esto se generaliza
a cualquier número de sistemas, y veremos algunos ejemplos adicionales cuando pasemos al entorno cuántico, que funciona exactamente de la misma manera,
salvo que tenemos matrices unitarias en lugar de matrices estocásticas, y con eso es suficiente sobre
información clásica por ahora.
Ahora centraremos la atención
en la información cuántica y cómo funciona para múltiples sistemas.
El patrón es el mismo que
para la información clásica.
Podemos ver múltiples sistemas cuánticos como sistemas compuestos únicos y aplicar lo que sabemos
de la lección anterior.
De nuevo, los productos tensoriales
jugarán un papel clave y, en conjunto, obtenemos una descripción de cómo funciona la información
cuántica para múltiples sistemas.
Eso es muy análogo
y matemáticamente similar a lo que acabamos de ver para
la información clásica.
Empezaremos con los estados cuánticos.
Los estados cuánticos de múltiples sistemas se representan mediante vectores columna con entradas de números complejos
y norma euclidiana igual a uno,
igual que los estados cuánticos
de sistemas individuales.
Esta vez, los índices de
los vectores de estado cuántico corresponden al producto cartesiano de los conjuntos de estados clásicos
de los sistemas individuales,
porque, de nuevo, ese es
el conjunto de estados clásicos del sistema compuesto.
Por ejemplo, si X e Y son qubits, entonces el conjunto de estados clásicos
del par XY juntos es el producto cartesiano del
alfabeto binario consigo mismo,
que podemos pensar como
el conjunto de todas las cadenas binarias de longitud dos.
Así que estos vectores que ves aquí son todos ejemplos de vectores de
estado cuántico de XY.
Si queremos, podemos escribir
estos vectores de forma alternativa así, donde tenemos un ket separado
para cada qubit,
donde el producto tensorial
entre ellos es implícito.
O también podemos escribir el
símbolo del producto tensorial explícitamente así, si lo prefieres.
Y otra opción es
poner como subíndice de los kets los nombres de los sistemas
que representan, así.
Y puedes hacer esto con
el símbolo del producto tensorial o sin él.
Eso a veces puede ser muy útil para no perder el hilo.
Estos son solo diferentes estilos para expresar los mismos vectores y podemos elegir el que queramos, el que prefiramos o
el que tenga más sentido
para la situación en cuestión. Cuando las cosas se complican,
por ejemplo, puede que decidamos que uno de
estos estilos aporta más claridad
y somos libres de elegir
la opción que queramos.
Los productos tensoriales de vectores de estado cuántico también son vectores de estado cuántico.
En el caso de dos sistemas, por ejemplo, si Phi es un vector de estado
cuántico de un sistema X y Psi es un vector de estado cuántico
de un sistema Y,
entonces el producto tensorial de Phi y Psi es un vector de estado cuántico de XY.
Llamamos a estos estados estados producto y, de manera similar a lo que vimos en el entorno probabilístico clásico, representan independencia
entre los sistemas X e Y.
Así que, por ejemplo, si una persona tiene un laboratorio
en algún lugar del mundo y crea un sistema X y lo inicializa al estado cuántico Phi
y otra persona en
otra parte del mundo inicializa de forma independiente un sistema Y al estado cuántico Psi,
entonces, si elegimos considerar XY como un único sistema aunque tenga dos partes o estén en distintos lugares del mundo,
el sistema compuesto XY se encuentra
en el estado Phi tensor Psi.
Todo esto se generaliza a
más de dos sistemas de manera natural.
Si tenemos estados cuánticos
Psi1 hasta PsiN de sistemas separados X1 hasta Xn, entonces el producto tensorial de estos n vectores
representa un estado cuántico, que también se llama estado producto del sistema compuesto X1 hasta Xn.
Aquí tienes un ejemplo de un
estado cuántico de dos qubits.
Aunque puede que no
lo parezca a primera vista, es un ejemplo de estado producto porque podemos escribirlo
como un producto tensorial, como puedes ver aquí.
Así que es un ejemplo de
estado producto; independientemente de cómo esté escrito, lo relevante es si es
posible o no escribirlo como un producto tensorial.
Este estado cuántico, sin embargo, que también es un estado de dos
qubits, no es un estado producto.
Es similar en espíritu al
ejemplo que vimos en el entorno probabilístico de dos bits aleatorios perfectamente correlacionados
y el mismo argumento revela que no puede escribirse
como un producto tensorial.
Así que vamos a mover esto aquí y a ver el argumento con un poco más de detalle.
Imaginemos que podemos
escribir este estado como un producto tensorial de
dos vectores Phi y Psi.
La entrada correspondiente
al estado clásico 0,1 es cero para este vector, lo que podemos ver con solo mirarlo.
Esto implicaría, sin embargo, si el vector fuera un producto
tensorial de dos vectores, que la entrada cero de Phi
multiplicada por la entrada uno de Psi
sería igual a cero, pero eso significa que
la entrada cero de Phi o la entrada uno de Psi es igual a cero
o ambas podrían ser iguales a cero, pero eso contradice el hecho
de que estos dos productos deben ser ambos distintos de cero.
Son iguales a uno
sobre raíz de dos. El argumento es de hecho prácticamente
idéntico al que teníamos en el entorno probabilístico.
No hay nada exclusivamente
cuántico en todo esto.
En cualquier caso, lo que encontramos es que el estado original no es un estado producto.
Fíjate que no es importante
que estos dos números sean uno sobre raíz de dos.
Lo único que importa es que
ambos valores sean distintos de cero.
Este estado cuántico en particular
es muy interesante. Es un ejemplo de un
estado entrelazado de dos qubits.
Hablaremos más sobre el
entrelazamiento más adelante en la serie.
El entrelazamiento puede ser complicado, especialmente cuando hablamos
de estados cuánticos en la formulación general
de la información cuántica,
pero aquí, en la descripción simplificada de la información cuántica, el entrelazamiento equivale a la ausencia de independencia.
Así que para un vector de estado cuántico,
si no es un estado producto, es un estado entrelazado,
y este estado en particular
se considera comúnmente como
el ejemplo arquetípico de un estado cuántico entrelazado.
De hecho, a veces
pensamos en este estado como la representación de una unidad de entrelazamiento, especialmente cuando
pensamos en el entrelazamiento
como un recurso que puede usarse
para hacer cosas interesantes.
El estado cuántico del que
acabamos de hablar es uno de los cuatro llamados estados de Bell, que puedes ver aquí
junto con los nombres
que se usan comúnmente para estos estados: Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus y Psi minus.
Todos están entrelazados
y forman una base para el espacio de todos
los vectores que representan estados de dos qubits.
Así que estos cuatro vectores juntos
se denominan la base de Bell.
Es una colección de estados cuánticos muy
frecuente, nombrada
en honor a John Bell, un físico que realizó
contribuciones muy importantes
al estudio del entrelazamiento en los años sesenta.
Aquí tienes un par de ejemplos conocidos de estados cuánticos de tres qubits.
El primero se llama estado GHZ.
Es algo parecido al estado Phi
plus que acabamos de ver, pero para tres qubits en lugar de dos.
Y el segundo ejemplo se llama estado W y tiene el aspecto que ves aquí: es uniforme sobre
las tres cadenas binarias
de longitud tres que tienen
exactamente un bit igual a uno.
Ninguno de estos estados es un estado producto y ambos tienen propiedades interesantes y aparecen con bastante frecuencia como ejemplos, así que conviene conocerlos
y los veremos de nuevo.
A continuación hablaremos sobre
las mediciones de sistemas en estados cuánticos.
Siguiendo el mismo razonamiento
que hemos seguido hasta ahora en la lección, que es pensar en múltiples sistemas
como si fueran sistemas individuales. Llegamos de inmediato a una descripción de cómo funcionan las mediciones de
múltiples sistemas cuánticos
siempre que todos los
sistemas sean medidos.
Es decir, si tenemos algún
vector de estado cuántico Psi que representa un estado cuántico de n sistemas en tupla
X1 hasta Xn y medimos
el sistema compuesto completo, lo cual equivale a medir
cada uno de los sistemas individuales, entonces cada posible n-tupla
de estados clásicos será el resultado de la medición
con probabilidad igual al
valor absoluto al cuadrado de la entrada de Psi que
corresponde a esa n-tupla.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos
un par de sistemas XY en este estado cuántico de aquí, entonces si medimos ambos sistemas,
obtendremos el resultado cero corazones, es decir cero para la medición de X y corazones para la medición de Y
con probabilidad nueve veinticincoavos y obtendremos el resultado uno
velocidades con probabilidad 16/25.
Eso es bastante directo. Básicamente estamos ignorando el hecho de que son dos sistemas separados y los estamos viendo como si
fueran un único sistema,
pero esto plantea la
siguiente pregunta natural, que ya consideramos
en el contexto clásico.
Supongamos que tenemos dos sistemas X e Y que están colectivamente
en algún estado cuántico y no medimos ambos, sino que
solo medimos un sistema.
Digamos que medimos el sistema X y no hacemos nada a Y.
Por supuesto, también podemos preguntar qué pasa si medimos Y y no
X, y más en general qué pasa si tenemos
tres o más sistemas
y medimos algún subconjunto propio de ellos. Pero una vez que tengamos una
respuesta a esta pregunta, tendremos respuestas a
esas preguntas también.
Sabemos que en general
un vector de estado cuántico del par XY toma la
forma que ves aquí, asumiendo como siempre que sigma y gamma
son los conjuntos de estados clásicos
de X e Y respectivamente.
Las entradas de este vector están
denotadas por alpha ab que varía sobre todas las posibles elecciones de a y b,
y pueden ser cualquier número complejo que haga que este vector
sea un vector unitario.
Ahora ya sabemos que si
ambos sistemas son medidos, entonces obtenemos las probabilidades para los diferentes posibles resultados
tomando el valor absoluto al cuadrado de la entrada correspondiente.
Y así si solo se mide X, entonces la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado particular a viene dada por esta expresión,
simplemente sumamos sobre todos los
posibles resultados b, que podrían obtenerse
si Y también se midiera aunque no lo fue.
La idea es la misma que en
el contexto probabilístico.
La probabilidad de obtener
un resultado particular cuando se mide X no puede
depender de si Y también fue medido o no.
Así que esto nos dice cuáles
son las probabilidades para los diferentes posibles resultados.
Además, habrá algún
cambio en el estado de Y como resultado de haber
realizado esta medición sobre X y haber obtenido un resultado particular.
Así que veamos cómo funciona esto.
Similar a lo que hicimos en
el contexto probabilístico, podemos expresar el
vector de estado cuántico Psi como ves aquí
donde Phi a es este vector para cada elección de un estado clásico a del sistema X,
estamos usando la bilinealidad
del producto tensorial igual que antes.
Solo que ahora hemos elegido nombrar
estos diferentes vectores Phi a, simplemente por conveniencia.
Ya observamos que la probabilidad de que la medición produzca
cada posible resultado a es como ves aquí,
pero ahora podemos ver que esta probabilidad es igual a la norma de Euclides
al cuadrado del vector Phi a,
y ahora como resultado de la medición de X que da un resultado particular a, tenemos que el estado cuántico
del sistema compuesto XY
se convierte en este estado que
ves aquí.
Igual que teníamos para sistemas individuales, el estado colapsa en esencia, pero no colapsa
completamente en general,
solo colapsa en la medida necesaria para ser consistente
con la medición de X que produce el resultado a.
El estado cuántico de Y se convierte en Phi a normalizado, lo que significa que
dividimos por su norma de Euclides
para que se convierta en un vector unitario. Esto es análogo a lo que ocurrió en el
contexto probabilístico donde en lugar de dividir
por la norma de Euclides,
dividíamos por la suma
de las entradas de Phi a para obtener un vector de probabilidad.
Pero aquí porque estamos
hablando de estados cuánticos, dividimos por la norma de Euclides
para obtener un vector de estado cuántico.
Veamos un par de ejemplos para ver cómo funciona esto
para un estado específico.
Aquí está el estado que consideraremos. Asumimos que X e Y son qubits y están en este estado particular Psi.
Y supongamos que se mide X.
Comenzamos escribiendo el estado
Psi como ves aquí, aislando efectivamente los
factores de la base estándar de X
y tensándolos con lo que necesitemos para obtener el estado original.
Igual que en la descripción general
de hace un momento.
La probabilidad de obtener el resultado cero es la norma de Euclides al cuadrado
de este vector de aquí.
Lo que tensamos con ket cero en nuestra expresión del vector Psi.
Así que la probabilidad es tres cuartos, y condicionado a
obtener el resultado cero.
El estado cuántico del
par XY se convierte en esto, donde normalizamos el
vector tensado con ket cero,
y eso equivale a
dividir por la raíz cuadrada de la probabilidad que
acabamos de calcular.
Luego podemos simplificar
y esto es lo que obtenemos.
La probabilidad de obtener el
resultado de medición uno se calcula de manera similar.
Tomamos la norma euclidiana al cuadrado
de este vector aquí. Lo que se tensa con ket
uno en nuestra expresión de Psi.
Y la
probabilidad resultante es un cuarto, lo cual tiene que ser, claro, porque nuestras probabilidades
tienen que sumar uno.
En este caso, el estado cuántico de XY se convierte en esto, donde de nuevo normalizamos dividiendo por la norma euclidiana.
de modo que obtenemos este
vector de estado cuántico como resultado.
Se usa el mismo método
de manera simétrica si se mide Y en lugar de X.
Aquí está el vector de estado cuántico original, y esta vez, como
se mide Y en lugar de X,
expresamos el vector Psi
como ves aquí, donde esta vez aislamos los
vectores de base estándar de Y
en lugar de X, tensando
con lo que necesitemos para obtener una expresión de Psi.
Haciendo el cálculo, que puedes verificar
pausando el vídeo si quieres.
Vemos que la probabilidad
de obtener el resultado cero es cinco octavos esta vez, y aquí está
el vector de estado cuántico
que resulta condicionado
a obtener ese resultado.
Y la probabilidad de obtener el
resultado uno es tres octavos, en cuyo caso este es
nuestro vector de estado cuántico.
Puedes usar exactamente el mismo método en caso de que tengas más de dos sistemas y se mida cualquier subconjunto propio de ellos.
Y hay un ejemplo
en el contenido del libro de texto para esta lección que puedes
consultar si te interesa.
En resumen, siempre podemos dividir los sistemas en dos colecciones separadas: los que se miden
y los que no.
Y una vez hecho eso, recurrimos al método
que acabo de describir, y así es como funcionan las mediciones para múltiples sistemas cuánticos.
Y ahora, por último, pasamos a las operaciones
unitarias sobre múltiples sistemas.
Usando la misma idea básica de que múltiples sistemas pueden verse como sistemas compuestos únicos.
Concluimos lo que ves
escrito aquí en pantalla: las operaciones cuánticas sobre sistemas compuestos están representadas por matrices unitarias,
igual que en los sistemas individuales, y específicamente las filas y columnas de esas matrices unitarias corresponden al producto cartesiano
de los conjuntos de estados clásicos de cualquier colección de
sistemas de la que estemos hablando.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos un sistema X
cuyos estados clásicos son uno, dos y tres, e Y es un qubit,
entonces la matriz que ves aquí es un ejemplo de una matriz unitaria que representa una
operación sobre el par XY.
Los detalles de cómo ordenamos los productos cartesianos de los que hablamos antes no importan mucho para
este ejemplo; es simplemente una matriz de seis por seis
que resulta ser unitaria.
No tiene nada de especial, aunque está construida a partir de un
par de matrices importantes.
La cuestión es que podrías
elegir cualquier matriz unitaria de seis por seis y representaría
una operación unitaria sobre XY.
Si aplicamos una colección de
operaciones unitarias de forma independiente, cada una en su propio sistema, entonces la acción conjunta de todas ellas
sobre el sistema compuesto está
dada por el producto tensorial.
Y aquí en pantalla puedes ver un enunciado más preciso
de ese hecho.
Si nuestras operaciones unitarias están descritas por las matrices unitarias U1 hasta Un, una para cada uno de nuestros sistemas,
entonces la acción combinada
sobre el sistema compuesto está dada por el producto
tensorial de U1 hasta Un.
De nuevo, similar a lo que teníamos en el caso probabilístico, un ejemplo importante es que
aplicamos alguna operación unitaria
U a un sistema X y no hacemos
nada a algún otro sistema Y.
La operación sobre XY que obtenemos es U tensada con la matriz identidad.
La matriz identidad
describe no hacer nada a Y.
A veces es útil escribir explícitamente que esta matriz identidad
corresponde al sistema Y, solo para que las fórmulas queden más claras.
Y una opción es darle a
la matriz identidad un subíndice como este que indica el sistema sobre el que actúa.
Cuando es suficientemente claro, normalmente no nos molestamos con el subíndice, pero cuando las cosas se complican más, puede ser muy útil.
Y también podemos considerar
el caso simétrico donde se aplica alguna operación
unitaria V a Y y no se hace nada a X,
y esta vez la operación
unitaria resultante sobre XY está representada por este
producto tensorial de aquí.
Y de nuevo, podemos poner un subíndice en la
matriz identidad si ayuda.
Aquí hay un par de ejemplos concretos.
Si X e Y son qubits y realizamos
una operación Hadamard sobre X y no hacemos nada a Y, obtenemos la matriz que ves aquí.
Si en cambio realizamos la operación Hadamard sobre Y y no hacemos nada a X, el orden del producto
tensorial se invierte.
Y así obtenemos la matriz
que ves aquí.
No toda operación unitaria
en un sistema compuesto puede expresarse como un producto tensorial.
Si tenemos un producto tensorial,
entonces tenemos independencia.
Y hay algunos ejemplos bastante
fundamentales de operaciones que claramente
no actúan de forma independiente en múltiples sistemas.
Por ejemplo, si X e Y tienen
el mismo conjunto de estados clásicos, que podría ser cualquier
conjunto de estados clásicos sigma,
entonces podemos pensar en la
operación swap sobre el par XY.
Esta operación no cambia el orden de los dos sistemas, seguimos teniendo X a la
izquierda e Y a la derecha, sino que representa
intercambiar el contenido
de los dos sistemas. Aquí puedes ver eso expresado
en forma de ecuación donde tenemos un producto
tensorial de dos estados cuánticos.
Otra forma de escribirlo es como
una matriz, como vemos aquí.
La forma de interpretar
esta descripción es que te dice qué ocurre con los vectores de la base estándar.
Y una vez que sabemos qué ocurre
con los vectores de la base estándar, sabemos qué ocurre con
estados cuánticos arbitrarios por linealidad,
lo cual también es válido para
esta expresión de aquí.
Así que esta operación en particular resulta ser tanto una operación determinista como una operación unitaria.
Si X e Y son qubits, por ejemplo, obtenemos esta
representación matricial aquí.
Aquí hay una conexión interesante
entre la operación swap y los cuatro estados de Bell, que se muestran aquí
para mayor comodidad.
La operación swap deja intactos los
primeros tres, pero añade un signo menos delante
del estado Psi menos,
así que hay algo
especial en ese.
Puedes verificar estas ecuaciones directamente mirando estos vectores y considerando qué ocurre
con los estados de la base estándar
al intercambiar los dos estados clásicos de los primeros tres estados de Bell,
no ocurre nada: obtenemos el mismo estado con el que empezamos.
En el cuarto caso, sin embargo, el signo menos efectivamente
se mueve de un término al otro cuando realizamos el swap de los estados clásicos,
y eso equivale a multiplicar el vector por menos uno.
Así que realizar la operación swap saca de alguna manera un signo menos
de este cuarto estado de Bell.
Hablaremos más sobre
estas ecuaciones más adelante, pero ahora pasemos a
otro tipo de operación: una operación controlada.
Vamos a suponer que X es un qubit e Y es cualquier sistema que quieras.
Si U es una operación unitaria sobre Y, entonces una operación U controlada sobre XY es la operación que
se expresa aquí.
Primero, usando la notación directa y luego usando lo que se
llama una matriz de bloques, basta con imaginar que rellenas
esta matriz más grande
con las más pequeñas, donde estos ceros representan matrices
rellenas de ceros.
Así que cada uno de estos cuatro bloques representa una matriz con un número
de filas y columnas que coincide con el número
de estados clásicos de Y.
La idea de una operación controlada, que ya encontramos
en el contexto clásico cuando hablamos de la
operación NOT controlada,
es que si X está en cero,
entonces nada le ocurre a Y.
Pero si X está en uno,
entonces U se aplica a Y.
Así que X se llama el qubit de control, e Y se llama el sistema objetivo, que en general no
tiene por qué ser un qubit.
Como ejemplo concreto,
que acabo de mencionar, tenemos la operación NOT controlada.
Si el primer qubit está en
cero, no ocurre nada. Y si el primer qubit está en uno, entonces una operación NOT o, equivalentemente,
una operación sigma X se
aplica al segundo qubit.
Y aquí está su representación matricial.
Estamos hablando de dos qubits aquí, así que también podríamos
decidir que el segundo qubit es el control y el
primero es el objetivo.
Para describir esa operación, simplemente intercambiamos el orden
en el producto tensorial, y el resultado es la matriz
que ves aquí.
Si en lugar de una operación NOT controlada, consideramos una sigma
Z controlada o una operación Z controlada.
Obtenemos esta representación
matricial aquí. Y para esta, en realidad no importa
cuál es el control y cuál es el objetivo.
Obtenemos el mismo resultado de cualquier forma.
Podemos ir más lejos y considerar una operación swap controlada.
Y aquí estamos hablando
de intercambiar dos qubits, así que terminamos con tres qubits cuando incluimos el qubit de control.
Su representación matricial
tiene esta forma.
Es una operación bastante especial y se conoce como operación Fredkin, o más comúnmente Fredkin gate.
Cuando pensamos en ello
como un gate en un circuit, hablaremos de los circuits en la próxima lección.
El último ejemplo es una operación
NOT controlada-controlada, que de nuevo es una
operación sobre tres qubits.
Y aquí está su representación matricial. Esta operación es mucho más
conocida como operación Toffli o Toffoli gate.
La discutiremos con más detalle
y veremos por qué tanto esta como la operación Fredkin son operaciones muy importantes
en una lección posterior.
Y eso es el final de la segunda lección. En esta lección, hablamos de cómo funciona la información cuántica para múltiples sistemas.
Espero que te unas a mí pronto para
la tercera lección, que trata sobre circuits cuánticos,
protocolos y juegos.
Hasta la próxima.